لاجل دعم ضحايا الزلزال شيف عمر الشهير
على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي لديبات نجما
في عالم الطبخ دخل الى مناطق الشمال
السوري والجنوب التركي وذلك بهدف توزيع
المساعدات على الاهالي المتضررين من
الزلزال هناك راغبا في تسليم المساعدات
بنفسه وباليد وهي عباره عن مواد طبيه
بكميه جيده بالاضافه الى المواد الغذائيه
حيث سيتم تسليم المواد الطبيه الى اداره
المشافي عبر مديريات الصحه التابعه لوزاره
الصحه في الحكومه الموقفه كما يروي
لمتابعيه المشهد الماساوي الذي خلفه
الزلزال من ارض الواقع
الوضع هناك يا جماعه كارثه كارثه يعني
بمعنى الكلمه يعني لما دخلنا انطاكيا
الساعه اربعه الصبح ماشيين بالسياره يعني
عم بقول لهم شوفي ليش العالم هون نايمه
على اليمين وعلى اليسار ما حد بنيات
مغطينهم حرام وجع الناس كتير صعب
صدقوني كتير ناس قربت ما بدنا مساعدات لا
بدنا شي نحن بدنا نقعد ببيت يعني نتقاوى
[موسيقى]
من اسطنبول للشيف عمر الشافي يسعد صباحك
اهلا بك معنا في صباح العربيه مره جديده
هذه المره من اسطنبول
يا هلا اهلا وسهلا يسعد صباحكم يا رب طب
شاف حدثنا اكثر عن هذه التجربه وكيف جاءتك
الفكره
بصراحه اول يوم صار فيه زلزال عاد تفكر
انه انا شو اعمل شو ساوي
حسيت رب العالمين الهمني انه انت فيك
تساوي كتير يعني انه انا ما حطيتك بهذا
المكان لحتى بس هيك تضل قاعد تتفرج قررت
انه انا انزل على
جنوب التركي على انطاكيا اكثر مكان فيه
سوريين نزلنا ضلينا تقريبا خمس ايام هنيكه
بعدها رجعنا لاسطنبول عبينا كمان التريلا
وشاحنات مواد غذائيه
حبيت اكون انا موجود مع الناس ليش لحتى
يكون في دعم معنوي قدر الامكان
يعني حاول قدر الامكان بس يعني يطلعون من
الشيء اللي هن فيه لو لحظه واحده
اعطيهم امل بالحياه اعطيهم انه هذا الشيء
حينتهي يعني هذا الشيء ما حيضل هيك وانا
كل كل حدا كنت التقى فيه صدق هذا الوقت رح
يمرق يعني هذا الوقت العصيب رح يمرق ان
شاء الله رح يمرق فحبيت تكون معهم يعني
بكون في دعم معنوي اكثر طب شيف عمر يعني
انت عايش باسطنبول منذ سنوات
وخصوصا يعني لحظه وقوع الزلزال وبنعرف
يعني ما طال الزلزال اسطنبول ولكن وين
كانت اولويتك الولايات التركيه المدمره
ولا الشمال السوري
الصراحه كانت اولويتي هي اقرب مكان
بالنسبه الي يعني اقرب مكان واكثر مكان
فيني اوصل عليه بسرعه يعني لانه نحن وصلنا
على منطقه الزلزال بعد 24 ساعه من حدوثه
اذا بدي ادخل انا على الشمال السوري بعد
حدوث الزلزال فورا بدي استنى زون اذن لحتى
ادخل بدي استنى تجهيز الشاحنه وكثير اموره
الطرقات مسكره يعني ما تنسي انه الطرقات
كلها مهدمه مسكره يعني حتى الطرقات اثرت
بالزلزال فدرسنا ولقينا اقرب نقطه لنا
مدينه انطاكيا مع انه في مدن ثانيه تدمرت
بالزلزال لكن مدينه انطاكيا بتحوي عدد من
السوريين جدا هائل
فحاولنا يعني نروح على المركز وهي المدينه
الصراحه كلها متدمره يعني ما يعني مع
الاسف ما بقي فيها شيء مدينه بكاملها
الفهد طيب شاف انتم موزعتم مواد غذائيه
وزعتوا مواد طبيه حدثنا عن هذه التجربه
كيف تتم عمليه المساعده والاغاثه وشو اكثر
شيء بيحتاجوا المتضررين
لكون صريح معك اليوم بعد كل شي اكثر شي
بيحتاجون المتضررين
يعيشوا بامان يعني اكثر من الناس مالها
بحاجه يعني مواد غذائيه ولا بحاجه الناس
بس بدها مكان ترتاح فيه بدي امان بعد كل
شي صار فيها اليوم بعد عشر سنين بعد كل
هالدمار يعني ناس بدها ترتاح يعني اليوم
نحن عم ندور الصراحه على حل الجزري اكيد
المواد الطبيه مهمه وزعناها هنيك على
المشافي بالشمال السوري اكيد المواد
الغذائيه مهمه لكن صدقيني صدقيني الاهم هو
انه هاي الناس يعني لا اله حل جذري خلص
تقعد ترتاح تعيش بامان فرصه عمل يعيشوا
حياتكم
لماذا دائما تبدا
لماذا دائما تبدا المزايدات خصوصا عندما
تبدا المساعدات كيف ترد وتعلق على من
يتهموك مثلا بالمتاجره بمنكوبيه الزلزال
وخصوصا عندما اعلنت بانه الكيس هو الاكبر
منذ سنوات الكيس الذي تم التبرع فيه في
الشمال السوري كيف ترد على هؤلاء
اول شيء هدول الاشخاص بالنسبه الي موجودين
بالحياه لانه اذا بالدوري ورا كل واحد
فيهم بتلاقيه قاعد عايش بمكان ما مرتاح بس
يعني تنظير تنظير من هدف وهدف الثاني
المشاهدات يعني كتير مع الاسف مستعده ترمي
فتن مستعد تعمل اي شيء بس مشان اللايك
فهذا الشيء جدا محزن انا الصراحه اللي
حكيته بالستوري جدا واضح لكن قطعوه مثل كل
مره انا تقريبا نزلت 150 ستوري خلال
الزلزال تركوا ال 150 ستوري ما حكوا عنهم
ولا كلمه خير اجوا مسكوا هاي الستوري اللي
انا حاكي فيها انه الناس وليس الناس
المنكوبين الناس اللي بتشتغل
اكياس مساعدات يعني في ناس موظفين
بيشتغلوا دائما كل ما تيجي الشاحنات
بساعدوا الناس يعني باجراءات يوميه مثلا
بعبوا الاكياس اذا فهن اللي قالوا لي انا
كلامي يعني انا عم بنقل مو كلام الناس ولا
قلت الناس جوعانين قالوا لي والله يعني
هذا الكيس عشره كيلو يعني عم نحاول يعني
نساوي الكيس منيح قدر الامكان قلت له
الناس اللي عم بتعبي يلي بتشتغل بالتعبايه
وليس الناس المنكوبين الناس بتشتغل وهاي
المقطع اللي شالوهن حذفوه قالوا لي انه هن
صار لهم خمس سنين
انا ما قلت ناس جوعانه بالعكس انا قلت نحن
شعب عزيز ولاننا بحاجه كيس ولانا بحاجه
اكل ولانا بحاجه شيء نحن اليوم بحاجه ماوى
اما هدول الاشخاص مثل ما قلت لك يعني ناس
بالنسبه الي غير موجوده بالحياه ناس بس
بيشوفوا الشر وبيسعوا للشر مع الاسف وهذا
الشيء اللي موصلنا لهون احنا بنتمنى لك كل
الت يعطيك الف عافيه وشكرا جزيلا لك من
اسطنبول شيف عمر